all right well since dying to know is
about the world of dying light
too there's still something else we need
to hear about
if you pardon the pun because we're
gonna be talking about the sound design
of dying light too if you've ever
wondered about where the roaring the
growling
just screaming that covers the streets
of the city at night comes from
then you're in the right place because
we're going to be talking to one of the
lead sound designers
to tell you more
senior sound designer tomx sheddak is
here with us today hello
hi nice to meet you you too hello um so
first question do the monsters have
their own language
they technically are not heard creatures
so
they didn't develop sounds to
communicate with each other although
there are some exceptions for example
howler when attacked
he would say scream to alert other other
infected and then you can get yourself
into
really big troubles very very very soon
let's talk about the process of actually
creating those sounds though
and so you have to imagine what a
volatile might sound like from
scratch and where do you even start with
that well you know the virus the
deformed
infected in very different ways and you
have to reflect it in their
in their voices so for example the
acid spitting monster you know has to
have some with some kind of
acidic characteristics some some watery
hissing stuff in it and there is the
banshee a
woman monster and her voice is
high-pitched
and vibrating and really really
scary so you work alongside your twin
brother wojtek and he
also records a lot of the sounds that
you use to create these monsters and we
actually have
a video of that process so we can have a
closer look at what that entails
ah
yeah so now you can see how how it works
we always start with the human throat
because all of the infected where humans
wants
and then the creative part is coming and
a lot of sound design magic is happening
also we have to cover a lot of emotions
in in the
infected voices because you have to know
i mean the player has to know
if the infected is is in pain or is
super aggressive or is maybe dying you
have to pass this message through the
voice and the message
has to be very very very clear so basic
monster like a biter has 700
voice assets so the scale is uh it's
enormous
yeah that's a lot to try and communicate
in sounds
so that's the monsters but what about
the entire city our city is dying
so we had to find these abandoned places
where there is no
sound of the civilization we visited
abandoned factories we
visited post-military bunkers we went to
the forest
at minus 15 degrees because it sounds
completely different than
in the summer and we climb up the
mountains it was a lot of
interesting places we wouldn't visit
without the dying light too and you know
at night with the good headphones
you can definitely enjoy it i cannot
wait to hear it it sounds like you've
got a
fascinating job i agree thank you so
much for coming in today thank you for
having me